on aurait pu croire que les ministres
nous reconduit dans leurs fonctions
respectives avaient été sanctionnés qui
les avait été écarté car pas forcément
en adéquation avec la politique
souhaitée par le président et sa
nouvelle équipe gouvernementale
finalement parmi les personnalités qui
ont été remerciés au début du mois de
juillet beaucoup ont déjà rebondi
la dernière en date c'est muriel
pénicaud l'ancien ministre du travail a
été nommée ambassadrice de la france à
l' ocde
un poste qu'elle doit à une proposition
de jean yves le drian son ancien
collègue est toujours ministre des
affaires étrangères pas de retour dans
le privé donc pour l'ancien drh du
groupe danone qui a pu compter sur de
solides recommandations pour obtenir ce
nouvel emploi
idem en ce qui concerne agnès buzyn
après avoir quitté le gouvernement pour
remplacer au pied levé benjamin griveaux
dans la course à la mairie de paris
l'ancien ministre de la santé peut-elle
aussi compter sur le soutien de
l'exécutif et celui du président de la
république en particulier
selon le canard enchaîné emmanuel macron
envisagerait de nommer agnès buzyn à la
tête d'universcience est un
établissement public qui regroupe le
palais de la découverte et la cité des
sciences et de l'industrie de paris
une belle opportunité pour celle qui a
connu un échec cuisant lors des
élections municipales de leur côté
christophe castaner essid et n'diaye ont
pu rebondir en interne au sein de la
république en marche
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur vise la
présidence du groupe de la majorité
présidentielle à l'assemblée tandis que
l'ancien porte parole du gouvernement a
été choisie pour intégrer la commission
nationale des talents au sein du parti
on pourra également souligner le retour
aux affaires de françois bayroux
éphémère garde des sceaux en 2017
le président du modem va être nommé haut
commissaire au plan
un recyclage assumer notamment pour
permettre à emmanuel macron de conserver
certains soutiens dans son entourage
comme l'attestent ces verbatim publié
dans un article du parisien
un été pour rebondir au gré de
nomination là où le président a besoin
d'envoyer des signaux et d'avoir des
relais des antennes décrypte un proche
sont jean aussi au vaste mouvement dans
la préfectorale
un été pour trouver à se recaser même si
ce n'est pas très nouveau monde
cela eut lieu de tout temps renvoie
d'ailleurs un marcheur c'est vrai que le
recyclage est une manoeuvre politique
ancienne mais compenser quelque peu
éculé le nouveau monde devait présenter
nouvelle manière de diriger de nouveau
visage aussi au final on constate que
certaines pratiques demeurent malgré les
critiques qu'elle suscite